hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast microbiome biomarker
discovery for diagnostic and therapeutic
applications I am seeing family roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider or virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning before we start there few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive event so police
asked questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by clicking on the green Q&A button
located out the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
questions and comments we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can do
you want a better look you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon at the lower right-hand
corner of the slide would do if you
can't hear receive this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button located at the top right
or use the Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window will try to
make sure to resolve any issues this is
an educational seminar and thus provides
free at continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CD button located at the bottom
left hand corner of your page and follow
the process for obtaining your credits
now let's get right to today's presenter
we're proud to welcome dr. to Santa's
time is the co-founder and director of
biomedics of second genome the
microbiome company that's leading the
development of novel medicine through
innovative microbiome science todd has
17 years of experience designing and
implementing by frenetic solutions for
analyzing microbio microbial community
dynamics he's a chief architect of green
genes an international effort to catalog
global microbial diversity that provides
microbial ecologist with reference
databases for DNA quality assessments
alignment and classification at second
genome he manages all informatics work
including identifying and recruiting
microbiome science leaders integration
of
tomek pipelines cloud deployment for big
data analysis and therapeutic pathway
discovery and when I'll turn it over to
Todd for this presentation thank you dr.
Pham so I'll get right into it this is a
great time to be in microbiology the
microbiome as you know has gotten very
high attention in lots of literature
lately and so I will be going through a
little bit of that so as a quick outline
for when we doing today first we'll
start off with why biomarkers are
important if you're a therapeutics
companies such as second genome or
you're working on biomarker discovery
just as pure sense a cadet academic
university or a biotech company and if
you haven't been familiar with the
methods of microbiome biomarker
discovery I'll be touching on that and
then we'll get right into overcoming
typical challenges that you will face or
you probably have faced already in
determining what the best biomarkers are
in a data set or in any data sets so
some of those challenges are places
where variation can creep in and also
how you're going to deal with all this
big data says then the last part i
actually had four cases for examples one
will be in finding biomarkers in
colorectal cancer the other one will be
microbial is to predict the drug
response a third one will be looking at
how you deal with biomarker described
which we have next generation sequence
data versus hybridization based data and
then the last piece will be and how you
integrate many diverse data types after
you've already found biomarkers for
instance to determine a therapeutic
approach so in this case we'll be
looking at metabolomics using main data
sets to determine metabolites that will
be interesting biomarkers so first topic
is why biomarkers are important to us
there because company like ours and
maybe yours and well it's it's important
because microbiome data analysis has
provided much more information now about
why disease may occur and why patients
may be
respond differently drugs and suggesting
new therapeutic approaches so for
instance there's been papers out about
how you can potentiate your new system
to work against cancer using microbiome
players we know there's connections to
gastritis and also pediatric patients
with irritable bowel syndrome have been
a hot topic as well as oral cancer and
asthma and many other topics too so any
kind of type of search for almost daily
disease area especially wants to
intercept the gut you'll find papers
where people are looking for biomarkers
that the microbiome can donate to the
problem and to allow better segregation
of patients so just a quick introduction
the second genome we love mining this
data different to find novel
therapeutics so although we're not
diagnostic diagnostics company the
biomarker part is one of those steps
along the way so we don't really get
bugs as drugs so you may have heard of
companies that are working on
communities of living organism to act as
therapeutics I'd call those probiotics
and maybe this next-gen probiotics
that'll be coming out we don't work so
much on live therapeutics but instead we
look for unique areas where we can find
a novel protein a novel peptide a small
molecule therapy and additional type of
pharmaceutical approach and we've built
a microbiome platform that allows us to
do this we identify and an express and
screen microbiome by act bioactives we
use a large native database of external
and internal data to develop our leads
and we found that you need genome assist
you need computational biologists you
need in vitro and in vivo experts in
laboratory and to build this entire
pipeline together 24 microbiome drugs
drug discovery and so that's what we how
would work here is we're not surely a
fire max company we're not purely a
laboratory company we have to span all
that and as I'm sure many you used to
and so we have a pipeline and our
pipeline of drugs are really we're going
to unmask unmet needs so our you know
first drug that's in phase one is a
small molecule we have additional
preclinical programs that are
lean proteins and butter discovery
programs where you have to do with
inflammation that evolved disease and we
think of our platform as a rapid
approach to deploy upon a new indication
with partners so the workflow for us
also parallels the types of focus that
you can take in branching off from raw
data to a therapy or raw data to a
Diagnostics on the left hand side you
can think of fecal transplants right if
you have hundreds of strains and a
microbiome therapy and that would be a
full fecal transplant for community uses
a therapy more reductionist from that
would be a consortium we have a defined
number of species that you pack and
defined relative abundances then provide
that as a pill for instance for a
therapy the more reduction would be just
to take a single strain or maybe an
engineered strain or naturally-occurring
strain that's the traditional probiotic
is in this in this area our focus is
even more reductionist it's it's to the
bioactive themselves so look for the
molecules that are produced or expressed
by the microbiome and that actually
affect the host directly and then we
bring those into a pill for instance
right so this would be the drug
development that goes from the bioactive
to the actual be candy and these last
two steps then it really is what our
focus is we found that from a left hand
side you have less specificity less
those response and control less electro
property and it's harder to control the
manufacturing of these substances or
these consortiums so to the right we
have greater ability to address all
those areas so the basic steps in the
platform that you might already have
thought threw up in your biomarker
discovery is you start off with a large
knowledge base or you have decided what
clinical samples are going to use and
then you probably have to deploy some
sort genomics know how to mine all that
data from now you list of novel Biomet
actives or markers and then if you test
them for therapeutic effect
test those in vitro screens or in vivo
screens and then course get to the end
so we think that the effect on host
biology is really important so you don't
just look at biomarkers look at
biomarkers that can in turn affect the
host and host this place the human and
then the novel the novelty and the
therapeutic approach in proteins and
peptides peptides is really large right
now there's so many unknown functions of
the proteins and peptides that are made
by the microbes that we can use those as
potential therapeutics themselves
directly in inflammation that evolved
disease and we think of this pipeline
you should think of this too as a rapid
system the data is coming out fast the
papers are coming out fast the
competitors are moving fast so and the
timeline that you want to think about if
you're starting this type of discovery
is about 3 to 12 months to go through
the raw data and reflected against
reference databases three to six months
to pick maybe your bio markers if you're
doing some therapeutic three to nine
months to get through some in vitro and
in vivo test to validate if you want to
go with a therapeutic for biomarker and
then of course from there to a novel
drug candidate is very various depending
on the type of own substance okay so
where we focus on is we've highlighted
here in blue which is after you take
your raw data reflect against reference
data and the third part down here is
this beneficial and detrimental
bacterial proteins and peptides we
search for to make actual protein and
peptide therapeutics so although there's
many ways you can branch off of this raw
data and the raw biomarkers that you're
going to collect a company of our size
we have to focus on on one system so we
picked a couple of these at our current
focus this year is since we have our
first stuff in phase one our next wave
is in protein and peptides so let's get
seen out to the abstract that you may
have read already before coming in here
and so just going to touch on a few of
things that we're going to be working
through today so remember that we have
challenges that exist in all phases from
sample collection all the way to data
processing
side views amazon cloud to overcome some
the big data questions we use some
machine learning and i'll go over i'll
touch on some of those topics as well
and then also you want to have a
platform that in our case doesn't just
do my bio markers but also creates new
hypotheses of disease causality and so
building a platform to do that as well
as always important and as if you will
be learning objectives here too if
you're following along too I gained
Sydney knowledge you should be able to
identify some disease areas or
microbiome analyses are applied by into
this talk you should be able to
differentiate what when you hear people
talking about 16 s profiling versus
meta-genome X versus meta
transcriptomics versus meta metabolomics
and so we'll go into a little bit of
that and they should identify where
variation occurs when you're going
through the data and then also hopefully
will vent ified the benefits of having a
control structure whole process as well
and these first four really are the main
part of the discussion here so first
methods so there's general methods that
you might see in the literature already
and you might have already deployed in
your production pipeline so I'm going to
go with five abuse the first and
probably least expensive and most
popular is a 16s ribosomal RNA gene
profiling so the in this case knowing
that every 16s gene that you collect
from a sample can be attributed to a
genome not always but there's many
genomes in the human microbiome that
have been well documented and so the 16s
genes help you know what genomes are in
your or in other words what species are
strains or in your sample so the benefit
of it is just you a pc application the
pcr products themselves can be
hybridized to an array or sequence
directly through the luma sequencing for
instance most popular approach now and
then you observe these counts or every
16s gene you try to find how many counts
fit into every bin have been might be a
genus or species depending on your
resolution of interest and then you're
looking for changes in those frequencies
across the data sets or across your
control and disease groups and the
downside about 16 s is that every 16s
gene is not necessarily unique for every
strain many strains share very similar
16s
gene and the 16s gene does only tell you
what the functions are in the microbiome
you can't infer some functions but you
really find the functions and really do
more strain analysis then recommends
shotgun meta-genome extras a second
bullet in this case you share up all the
DNA from your sample see any sequence
many DNA fabrics from many microbes I
put many not all for a certain for a
special reason I'll talk about that
later but really try and take a sample
of all the DNA fragments and then from
there you observing which genes are
changing their abundance and which tax
are changing in their abundance so you
have second dimension to the data that's
helpful for mining for biomarkers the
third approach which is actually even
more functional if you're asking what is
the microbiome doing at a certain point
in time we take a sample then meta
transcriptomics is the way to go so in
this case you shear up in sequence as
many messenger RNA fragments from the
microbiome as possible this could be a
stool sample a swab but in think of a
stool samples has many microorganisms
distressing different levels of their
genes you're trying to take a sample of
that and then observing which microbes
changing their expression levels
compared and we doing group comparison
or which gene itself or maybe a cake
orthologs group or a enzyme and class is
changing its abundance across the
expressions data sets and the fourth one
meta proteomics is when you fragment all
the proteins that you can from a sample
you collect spectra from them and again
you observe changes in microbial protein
abundances meta metabolomic then is when
you're collecting spectra from the
metabolites eat right click as many as
you can either you might look the
exercise of fraction or total cell by
States but in both cases you're going to
be observing changes in metabolize so
when they want to point out across all
these is that really be comparative
analysis is important we have many
partners who come to us with maybe
without a hypothesis based on a profile
there are samples using one or more
these methods and that's always
interesting of course but really the the
the findings that you want to look for
is Delta's changes in the abundant
certificate reproducible robust across
age technology so you have to have
comparison
to really capitalize on the investment
that you've made into this area so last
thing I want to point out is that you're
looking for reproducible changes in the
abundance of the features and those can
be become become biomarker candidates
okay so I put together a small list of
what i've seen to be the necessary and
cymatics capabilities that you'd want to
have in place if you're going to start
mining the microbiome for biomarker
discovery so i'll go into a lot of these
in our examples later on but just to
quickly go through them you need to have
a fish and compute capacity we choose
chose the Amazon Cloud for ours because
it's very elastic meaning when we need
more compute power it's easy to scale up
when we're not using it we're not paying
for it and then we went and built our
own software that bids for resources
queues are our queries and queues are
processing and mapping and then of
course monitors hollows are going and so
some for instance amazon has some of
those types of bidding and queuing a
monitoring systems built in see my
people take advantage of those but we
found you laughing you have to make a
custom type of cloud deployment for a
different pipeline so i'd be willing to
make some investment time there other
some companies have lotsa can be
powerthirst of their own a sort of a
government lab we had plenty of it there
so we could do a lot of analysis there
but I've also found that even those
large grids that might be owned by a
certain institution can get backed up
and so we've always preferred to go with
a cloud resource where if you need to
get something done you can bid high
enough dollars for it and get it done
that weekend if you need to or that
night next part is having reliable
reference databases so if you're looking
at bacterial products such as their
metabolites then you might have a
database of all the gene expression
changes that occur in a host when it's
when affected by the metabolite and so
that as important part 3 Fletcher data
against you might have a microbial
cheminformatics question and we found
that lots of the chemical resources out
there have various coverage for
microbial metabolites so we found that
finding it you know bill
your own system for that it's important
to there's many diverse diverse proteins
that are known and many of their
unknowns so building a database second
or using a database is covered all those
are important and then knowing all the
strains that are available all the
genomes for them as well as 16s genes of
strains that are cultured and yet to be
cultured are important too so the third
one is on this part here is on its input
an arrow here so you didn't make that
work so this next part is about raw data
so i want to highlight that because we
found that you take data from a paper
that's being analyzed during a certain
pipeline at a certain point in time you
might get one result but if you go back
to the raw data from many samples and
you are to process that off the same
pipeline with with the most up-to-date
reference databases then you're going to
have a better view of the types of
biomarkers that could be found and up on
the top right there's also software that
you might have to build for doing
different parts of your analysis and I'm
going to some of those later to all
those one of those large integrated
piece of software that's important if
you're looking at and in this case
metabolites that affect hosts and WLAN
examples and another exciting part how
is quantitative a noble metal
transcriptomic so this is when you don't
have a reference genome you're finding
new organisms in your data and you want
to find out which of their transcripts
have a quantitative shift in their
abundance this is difficult and you
don't have a genome to map to sew and
visit it'll take some effort to put this
in place and validate it and when when
you start looking for brand new proteins
you also feel like big data
visualization is unnecessary but I would
say is always helps the rest of team see
where your effort is going so it's
always hard to communicate big data to
maybe a set of biologists who aren't
used to looking at that scale so having
visualization techniques are important
and machine learning helps a lot we have
a lot of variables that you can't
predict okay
so when we talk about big data it's
because you might have some data in your
auspices but there's so much other data
that's already been made that you should
reflect yours towards that you want to
collect a large number these samples are
related to your samples so the sample
sources for us we have partnerships we
have obtained retrospective clinical
samples we also have perpective per pet
perspective studies which are ongoing
and data comes in from those and also
there's analysis public data sets so
pulling those all together and then this
essential images represents our cloud
that has many workers our data comes in
it gets cute workers pick it up process
the data in a set and protocol vimax
protocol and deposits the data back into
our buckets we call these buckets our
term that Amazon uses for data storage
locations that get backed up and they're
inexpensive and they're on demand so
you're not paying for hard drives you
just putting things in buckets as you
need them and then from there they can
move into a database for doing queries
so we found that after 41,000 microbiome
samples process with three different
diseases having 16s RNA meta
transcriptomics metagenomics many
different diverse data sets integrating
that into a big data analytic framework
we couldn't find thing off the shelf
that does that so we've had a builder
own system for that and but it's it's
been worth it because you learn a lot
along the way about the variation that
you find different data sets which I'll
talk about soon after you have your day
to organize usually when reflected
against a reference database and there's
right of them out there we support and
keep updated the green jeans database
and which is the last version that's up
on our website has a coverage of those
cultured and on culture organisms our
next version we rolling out is a
definite emphasis on the cultured
organisms that are found in the human
microbiome so at the beginning of the
green genes work it was environmental
and host associated microbes probably
imbalance and now there's definitely
since the sense the focus of microbiome
research and has increased a lot in
clinical space greetings is following
that as well so the next release will be
much more heavily geared towards the
microbes that are that are cultured
already and found with human microbiome
and the nice thing about using a co-pay
a reference databases that you're not
relying upon an author's description of
the taxonomy when they put it organism
into a database instead you have a
standardized system of assigning taxes
on the banks and taxonomic names across
all of your data so that you have a
comprehensive way to move around your
data and to find out which general is
which family is changing in abundance in
a certain disease area and then a couple
of databases we mentioned earlier was
this database where we keep track of how
microbial proteins or microbial
metabolites affect gene expression in
the host and so this database we called
the BP effect this bacteria product
effect database well so there's
literature mining that is done to find
out if you have a metabolite and this in
this case it's red arrow means its
metabolites has an increased effect upon
a protein this case we're looking at
il-10 production and then on the right
hand side this is a evidence of an edge
between two nodes in this case we have
14 which is a chemical that is under
microbial control it could be in this
case is being a documented inhibitory
effect upon il-10 so in this case this
is data that we generate in our lab
other dating on the left is generated
and found in literature and other lab so
the point that all together to build
what we call network of a basic graph
database that shows all the effectors of
gene expression that are known and we're
always adding to this as well so that we
have a fresh data set we can search that
for insights and then of course the chem
informatics and you might be an expert
in chem informatics and already found a
solution for this but when we looked at
the chem informatics systems that are
out there we've got my keg biopsych IPA
metabolize in I UPAC we have disagreeing
and nomenclature and identifiers and
some of them haven't worked well
organized that microbial metabolites so
we pulled those all together and built
our own rosetta stone between them we
call the mm database which tracks about
28,000 different microbial metabolites
and the other two parts that might be
important in your research is if you're
doing and work with add genes that
expressed proteins then the big protein
database is the important so this is
looking at not just you know human
proteins but all of my kroger proteins
which are much more diverse so when we
went through this process we found that
if we do have located all the proteins
that are publicly out there we step a
hundred million different proteins to
search against whenever we find new
proteins in our meta transcriptomics and
so we call this the HD probe database
the high diversity protein database and
that allows us to index will we find and
then on the right side here and when you
find new proteins or finding genomes you
want to determine or find you fragments
of genomes anyone determine that has
that genome already been sequenced or is
that strain available at a cultural
collection then keeping a strain
database up to date is important so
there's thousands of genomes that are
coming out every couple months and these
genomes are not getting into all the
public databases fast enough so we've
had a maintain our own that allows us to
quickly be able to search okay so this
next slide my advanced too much at first
but this is a case where you this is a
case we're using internal and external
data sets an integrated integrating
minim gives you fresh insights oh and
here's a case where we had inflammatory
bowel disease data these are it
specifically also colitis and patients
and controls and each dot on these plots
represents one host gene that changed an
expression so these are what are called
volcano plots where the more to the
right or left you are in a point that's
the greater the full change was from
health
and get tired to the top or bottom is
how significant that change was so upper
so genes that are Dossett are in the
upper left and right quadrants are the
ones are most significant so in this
case on the left-hand side we have genes
that are high in healthy state that are
knocked down when you have your knock
down their expression when you're in the
colitis condition and these are all
taken from biopsies so this is a case we
only have three datasets but typical
cases we're doing six of 10 datasets at
once and when you look at those then you
can find genes that are consistent
across data sets and so this is a
technique that's around the Geo a
website for a while it's really
important and and so you might have used
it before where you can overlap datasets
and then let's and false discovery
analysis and find a set of targets that
are not just one data set specific but
robust across data sets so this helps us
find outliers for instance two in the
same procedure we use for microbiome
data as well okay so now we're on to the
typical challenges that you're going to
face in finding biomarkers in microbiome
data and so the way want to overcome
these is there's two major classes of
are becoming so the first place play
series is in controlling source of
variation if you know this variation
that's going to rise up how do you
control it in the biospecimen collection
shipping storage in the how you extract
molecules how you prepare samples or run
pcr and then also in voiding the under
sampling problem which I'll talk about
and because under sampling can look like
large variations occurring but it's just
because the technique that's being used
secondly when we have all this data how
do you get all this data processed so
that's another challenge overcome so
here is a figure that's supposed to
represent the different places where
variation comes in and then this
integration of all this variation that
at the end gets spit out as a reliable
biomarker so on the very left hand side
the true biological variation that's
what you're trying to find you know how
much was the effect size of your bio
marker between two groups by taking the
account the natural biological variation
among that such the tube that you tested
that's really what you want to focus on
to get there though you have to make
sure that you as I go across from
clockwise around this circle you have to
make sure you have the right style
design and the right powers you haven't
depth of samples and by not having those
two things and in place that's going to
affect your ability to find a lot of
biomarkers obviously but then we've also
found that the way you collect storing
ship biospecimens and can have a big
effect the way you extract the molecules
the protocol you use will have an effect
and which technique you choose to
generate your data from the raw extracts
is important and would buy at the next
pipeline you choose will have an effect
and then if you have the ability to
confirmatory testing by using a second
platform or second test of course that
always helps you hone animal reliable
biomarkers so we've found that
standardizing from the outset is
important so when we go to retrospective
studies there's always a question of how
well was that sample preserved how was
it being extracted so our prospective
studies then are we have more ability to
have control so in that case we'll have
experimental design guidelines we
recommend to work with the clinician to
be able to obtain the sample in its most
preserved form and now we'll turn into
clinical protocols they'll also be
[ __ ] in placing patient questionnaires
and knowing what types of patients are
going for of course helps you have
exclusion criteria to give the right
people and then you collect the patient
metadata and you want to click that
assistant way at the outset because
always try to go back to your patients
of course that's more matted and ask for
more metadata and then there's a stool
collection storage and shipping
instructions sheet that we that we
produce for the clinician that gives
along with the stool that phrase the
steward genome collection kit and that
will be carried together explain to the
patient and then they'll be able to pack
it themselves and ship it
shipping label for instance and the
patients can ship the label a shifty
sample and directly to our laboratories
or sometimes a clinician collects many
samples at once stores them in a unified
way and ships and batches and then once
it arrived at our our lab then I'm like
the extraction protocols last tournament
to nucleic acids for instance in this
case and nucleic acids then go on to a
data collection system but having
protocols in place from the beginning
always helps remove some the variation
and I if you've done these types of size
before you might have found stew arrived
at a low temperature in some cases high
temperature in other cases or the stools
mix really well with the preservative
and in other cases you have a stool that
might have come clumpy it wasn't mixed
well organized with the preservative and
so that can bring in very source of
variation seven good protocols having
people well trained at the clinical
sites and then having these these
shipments happen right away on eyes in
our packaging or whatever packaging
decide and keeping that consistence
going to make a big difference okay once
you have let's say stool or your your
biospecimen in your laboratory the
choice of how you extract that specimen
is going to affect which types of
microbes that you're going to highlight
in your analysis so we did a test of
this back in 2005 when microbiome
science was just starting and we have
this capability look at many microbes at
once and we were wondering and are we
looking at the microbes that are most
revealed by our technique and not
necessary the whole spectrum of microbes
so what we did is we took in this case
one aerosol sample so we were looking at
them in this case we're looking at what
gets breed what kind of microbes get
breathed in by just people who are
outside at a four foot off the ground
had collectors grabbing and dust samples
and we wanted to find out how we can
find the full version of death samples
so we took the exact same large sample
of dust collected from that height and
from that one sample we split it into
five different groups are six different
groups of samples and then each sample
got
distracted at different durations of be
beating so the only protocol difference
in this process is how long we beat beat
so on the left-hand side will have four
tickets or a negative control and then
we have next step is only we just put
the the biospecimen into the the be
beating buffer but never even shook it
this is a zero second beat bidding the
next one's five seconds 20 seconds 45
seconds and then 10 * long afore and 50
seconds and then we ask ourselves with a
heat map for instance a showcase which
microbe which microbial families in this
case were highlighted by a certain be
beating so if you compare on left hand
side a couple of these different
families we had the photo bacteria ACA
and didn't show its greatest amount
until you got two for 50 seconds so this
is a case where if you want to highlight
flavor bacteria save your hypothesis
around that certain family then you want
to beep it at a longer duration to be
able to uncover that DNA and allow to be
available for your PCR whereas the other
case if you're focused on the sphingidae
CA which are in the Alpha pretty
bacteria down here at the bottom you see
that those are easy to see just without
any beeping at all just putting them to
lysis buffer pops them up and you're
able to access their DNA and it can be
be too long then there's signal drops
and you don't see as much abundance of
those organisms it's swamped out by
other DNA that gets em into the system
or it's being sheared up and so unable
to be amplified but the point is if you
just pick one protocol and you expect
that you're looking at all the different
microbes you're probably not so we
recommend that you run a spectrum of
tests on your extraction protocol to
make sure that you know what you're
looking at and what you're putting aside
and if your hypothesis is built up
enough around a certain family of
bacteria then you'll be able to make a
good decision about which them protocol
to use
the next thing is when you're looking at
biomarkers there's an understanding
problem in microbiome research that is
is very important but i would think that
most bioinformatics ists have seen it
understand it but maybe biologists
planning the experiment may not be as
aware and so I just want to make it
really clear what this problem is and
the take-home message you want to avoid
relying on present absent events because
the sampling technologies that are out
there it's very difficult to make a true
absent call there's a great article that
came out from rob knight and kappa rosso
and Jack gilbert it's an environmental
journal but the take-home message is
really really important they took the
English Channel and they sampled it
every day for a year and they sequenced
10,000 as sequences from every sample
the six 10,000 16s sequences and from
that they wrote a paper about organisms
being present and absent different times
of the year but then they took one
sample and sequence it much more deeply
they did over a million reads from that
one sample and they found that all the
organisms that were found throughout the
whole year we'll all all present in one
sample so this this basically changed
the idea that when you have an ecosystem
that you're studying it's more likely
that many of the organisms are always
present in some level but just in
different proportions and so I talked to
Jack Gilbert about this article he said
there's kind of I asked him you know is
it true that many things are many where
you never had everything's everywhere
but many of the microbes are really in
all different environments and I mean by
that all the humor associated microbes
are seen around the world are they are
many of them always in any stool sample
just until abundance he says well maybe
or maybe everything is everyone so any
one point in time there's probably some
level of an organism in a sample but you
might not just be detecting it because
you're not sequencing deep enough for
instance and so that's why is that and
the house are the let's say a parallel
wanna put is in depth of diving
think this will help make it come clear
so right now eadral we call deep NGS
next-generation sequencing is not deep
enough to really do present athletes and
calls and see everything in a sample and
here's why but if I think it something
very deep I figure out the Pacific
trench 30,000 feet deep and a deep
exploration event would go all the way
the bottom maybe a robot maybe a sensor
a sampling system you'd want to go all
the way the bottom of the sample at the
bottom and so now let's make a parallel
to one microgram with DNA so one
microgram at DNA that's very simple to
come by if you take a small in a one
gram of stool you're going to extract
lots of DNA there it's easy to get about
a microgram of that dissolved in twenty
microliters of buffer let's say you did
a pcr amplification off of a skin sample
for instance or a oral swab and you
might end up with a microgram of DNA
very easily now consider you sure that
up into 500 base pair of fragments now
if you do that if you run the
stoichiometry on that you're going to
get almost 2 trillion molecules so
that's um you know rounded down 10 to
the 12th or 15 10 to 12 so that's a
trillion pieces of DNA so let's say that
is my sample a trillion pieces of DNA
and I want to sample that so the
question is can NGOs technology really
sequence every piece of DNA and a sample
observe all the diversity well not
really I mean even if we sequenced from
one sample we went and sequence a
hundred million leads which is pretty
expensive and it's not would it
practically got to do that at scale and
if you can get a hundred million reads
of one trillion fragments that's
basically one 10,000 in a typical
library of 16s you might make a hundred
thousand reads not even 10 100 million
if you have a deep metagenomic
sequencing project then you'd probably
be about 10 million reads over hundreds
of patients and if you can do 100
million reads you're probably focused on
a very few number of patients all you've
got lots of capacity but even if you did
100 million so 1 10000 that's a huge
effort and that's really equivalent to
diving
three feet deep into this trench and
calling it a deep dive so whenever you
hear someone talking about deep
sequencing you really want to ask them
how many molecules was in the sample and
how many were sampled and then you can
put that in proportion mean find out if
you consider that to be deep sequencing
or not so with this what occurs then in
this case is they end up with we call
sparse data so when you have
next-generation sequencing data and if
you were to arrange in a table where
Rose might be all of the genes and
columns might be all of the samples you
don't encounter all the genes and all
the samples so many of the cells in your
self spreadsheet would be zeros for
instance your table wouldn't have you
know the density to have lots I gotta
turn off my phone excuse me okay so when
that occurs you can make these plots and
the top here is a plot that's showing
for some Cinco origin organism RNA seek
studies and it's trying to show the
relationship between how deep you
sequenced and how much of the total
genes that you could encounter were
encountered and on these different these
are different organisms different
studies that came out of a paulson paper
in Nature method 2013 but they found
that typically you might only find 15 to
eighty-five percent of all the genes you
could find an organism actually found
and and these are under typical
sequencing depths now that's somewhat of
a problem but there's statistical tests
that will overcome that problem of
sparsity but the the problem is much
worse when it gets down to a microbiome
data which has many organisms and many
genes here's a case where in the best
case you have a 16 s profile where
you've you've made bins of taxa and
you're trying to fill in those bins with
reads from different 16s observations
you made from your study so in this case
really it's it's more sparse you only
get about one to three percent of your
total Excel table having any data at all
in this case you can see the
relationship here that you find in among
study for instance where on the x-axis
is how deep you sequence any sample
the y-axis is how many different bins
that you were able to fill in something
and in this case Oh to use well if you
go up on this on this curve the deeper
you sequence the more diversity that
you're finding and so therefore your
spray the data out even more so when you
have lots of zeros in your data matrix
you have to be able to account for that
for the NGS data and you might not want
to look at the zeros as absent it's just
that what the sequence deep enough to
find out what the what the abundance was
okay and next point here just that
you'll have to write some sort of custom
software along the way and if you have a
certain interest for instance for us we
thought that functional inference from
bacterial population shifts was
estimated pretty well but some public
software projects but we went ahead we
had to make one else up to date with all
the new genome so we created one called
pie filling it helps us go from the
16-hour shifts the possible changes and
that can be happening functionally and
will be actually sharing that with the
public and management prep right now
also we found that there's a lot of
noise and NGS data besides the under
sampling problem there's also miss calls
bases that are that are juxtaposed in
this sequence themselves and you can
tell from the from the quality scores
that that type of small changes can make
you think there's more diverse student
it really is so program called clampers
being written here it's all ready to
have a submission for this start yep
dome is under review and nature methods
and this is a system where you can do
some noise correction in MGS amplicon
data before you do your physical
analysis and then also written software
for the 50 chip hybridization data
system which is another way of looking
at 16s data without sequencing but just
hybridizing in the high-throughput way
and that software is I've been described
or a 2015 my losi is a program that's
written biostatistician here Paul
McMurray and that's a great system that
you might want to use to help organize
your data and that's
public projects so you're welcome to it
and all I'll talk about in a minute and
this is in-house software for
integrating lots of types of data
streams okay so now let's get into some
examples so i can mentioned earlier
we're going to go through four examples
and i'll try to go to them pretty
quickly because i know time is running
out so the first one is diagnostic
biomarkers and clerk answer this will be
a stool data set from 16s and it's a
meta-analysis the next one is how we
link host of microbiome biomarkers to
propose new therapeutic routes in this
case we'll be using quorum biopsies
shotgun meta transcriptomics combined
also with host transcriptomics of
touched on machine learning applications
and then also do a comparison of 16s
that she took generation sequencing and
success hybridization to show the types
of data you might expect and the
strengths of weaknesses of each okay so
first thing to be aware of is this inter
study heterogeneity when you are doing
meta-analysis so here's a we call
ordination each point represents one
stool sample they're colored by which
study the sample came from and the
distance between any two points shows
how much overlap there is in the content
of what organisms were found so if two
points are close together they have very
similar presence/absence detection and
at the far apart they have dissimilar
presence/absence table of organisms and
so here what we found right away is on
the right hand side is alumina projects
on left hand side was 454 then the 454
project separated by which primers were
used to amplify up the certain variable
region of 16s gene and so keep this in
mind that you're not gonna your data is
going to have to be your methods we have
to be able to overcome this this problem
when we looked at biomarkers in
colorectal cancer using multiple
datasets we found a list of ones that
could be really useful so on the
left-hand side is a bunch of taxa and
then there's a plot that shows what the
observation was about that taxa in the
studies blue point is the combined
result off of many analyses in these
what we call forest plots but you can
see that although the Blue Point might
be on one side of the zero
meaning that's an increase on the right
hand side of in the disease state and a
decrease on the left hand side in the
disease state you can see that the error
bars span quite a bit quite a bit far
out there depending on which data set
you're looking at so a robust system you
know we'd have to take this into account
and maybe normalize of course on one
technology one data collection technique
and if you're going to pick a very few
number of biomarkers then you might want
to pick ones that are agreed upon by
multiple study cohorts and by multiple
technologies that there really is a
difference and for instance you can see
some cases here we have the whole span
of the error bars all on one side of the
zero and those ones might be once you
want to pick first this is a topic of a
poster that's also available if you want
more details and that's connected to
this lab roots presentation to from the
website ok then after you have this data
and you organized it your choice of
bioinformatics pipelines will make a
difference on your findings so here we
take the baton same data set and it ran
through different pipelines one pipeline
a popular one called chyme Chinese the
green genes reference database and we
ran the default system of chime which is
basic what's called closed reference
where every read is reflected against a
pre clustered version of the database
and you count how many times you hit
every cluster in the database and that's
your tea table the second pipeline we
used the strain select database which I
mentioned earlier is our as our internal
effort to keep all the strains organized
all the data about each stage strain
connected well and then when we have 16
s data we can connect it to the strain
that most likely it came from and then
after we do this strain select mapping
the only use some of the techniques that
are part of a you parse package to
account for removing errors or removing
sequences are highly errant from that we
have an OT table as well so soon from
pipeline soup and ODU tables and then we
use random forests in this case to
determine which data set would be the
most useful predicting disease or
predicting is that a sample came from
patient versus a healthy patient so
pipeline ones on the left and the big
difference here is a specificity with
seventy percent on the right hand side
we had ninety percent specificity so we
were able to achieve higher specificity
as the biggest difference in this case
so that means that in our case ninety
percent of negative calls were true
negatives so organizing your data
against a modern database in a very
systematic way will help in the
deciphering the data using the to pick
your biomarkers by the way this work was
done with UT Health and there's some
authors down here also a bailar that's
working on this publication right now
too okay the next topic is how you doing
if you want to integrate this data to
make therapeutic inferences then you
might have one its biospecimen with many
other types of data in this case on the
left hand side we're showing a picture
of a biopsy a biopsy has microbes if the
biopsy has human cells so we accept like
the RNA and DNA sequence hybridize both
to the arrays or NGS systems and then we
end up with mRNA profiles we end up with
Kang orthologs and we end up with an tak
sonic shifts as well so the system we
would do that with is basically mostly
bioinformatics out the sequences are
created after moving them to poor
quality ones we separate host ones by
mapping them to the human genome then we
have leftover repeated microbial
sequences and we can map those two known
proteins of known functions and then the
host RNA can be mapped to their genes
and gave special levels and then we're
trying to find significant changes that
occur in the microbes that have
mechanisms of interactions that are
plausible on the host side so we use a
system called causal network analysis to
determine the microbial or determine the
host changes in this case we find we
regulators of the gene expression that
could be controlling downstream effects
of other genes on the host mapped as a
volcano plot here we're showing us after
looking at multiple datasets multiple
cohorts and the biopsies gene expression
of the host from those we can find
certain genes that are always up regular
rated R sorry not jeans but regulators
that control other genes that are always
activated and about loneliness s I have
doesn't read and also ones that are
deactivated or more activated health on
the green side these can be receptor
cytokines kinases and but the key part
is after we find these root regulators
if we know that there's a microbial
metabolites that has affected that in
past literature we look for evidence
that that metabolite is in a microbial
data so this is the connection piece
then a left hand side after skating
through the microbial day that we
collected from the biopsies we predict
certain reactions that are over abundant
and some they're under abundant in the
microbiome and we know they have a
festering compound and if that compounds
none of the regulator of gene expression
we call that a connection and then those
compounds and go on to our screening
assays and laboratory so we call that
ola because it's a hypothesis
origination making assistant it doesn't
do the work for you but it assists you
in connecting the data to find
metabolites that could be points of
interaction and general machine learning
applications are important too as we
talked about before disease Diagnostics
with be CRC data set and there's also a
patient stratification that you can be
done if you have patients that respond
and don't respawn all these data sets
are all these microbial techniques can
produce data that could be fit into
determining patient ratification the
last one is peptide therapeutics which
is a machine learning application that
comes naturally after gallery data so if
you have kept types of known
interactions the specific human
regulatory gene proteins and then you
know those proteins structural
physicochemical attributes then you can
run a machine learning algorithm over
the proteins that you've unearthed to
find new candidates that also might
interact with a with a host protein
target and foreign stratification we did
a great study we had three thousand
samples and then from those we had two
thousand different microbiome features
which are basically taxa or higher order
taxi like higher ranks families classes
for instance and then each
each sample had many different clinical
metadata variables as well so much more
quite a few variables so we tried a few
different machine learning techniques
after comparing the results you can
identify certain features that are
predictive of what a drug can respond
and also you can measure how successful
your predictor was considering after you
can cross the cross validation and
decide if you want to take that that
diagnostic further and large data sets
of course are really helpful for this
the last example is from CF model
organism this hamster if you wanted to
determine which types of microbes would
be indicative of a microbe let's say the
colon be resistant to see this infection
versus acceptable versus resistant so in
this model a hamster gets a dose it from
the myosin on day zero before day zero
they're resistant to a challenge of CW
to sell the octo did clindamycin is
administered there's some sort microbial
knock down that allows you to be allowed
a hamster be susceptible and then later
it recovers to resist in them what
notice from this curve the cancer is not
returned to the baseline right away but
even though it's after 15 days it has a
return to baseline there's still
resistance acquired so the question is
what biomarkers would let you know if
you're susceptible resistant to the
challenge so we took the stool we ran it
through two different pipelines one
would be a v4 lumina pipeline which
we're pulling out her the top and also
on a follow chip so dif- Fortier is the
sequencing and uses a small section of
the 16s gene the follow chip uses the
whole gene the sequencing we generated
fifty thousand reads per sample and
under fifty thousand reads for each one
about 20,000 50,000 across the data sets
the fellowship of course all one
trillion molecules get placed onto the
array as to try it to hybridize and to
their probes and at the both case we
have ot abundance tables in both cases
you can do a broad separation
we're and the blue circles is the
starting stage on the air set blue
polygons on the orange polygon is where
you have the susceptible stage and then
and the purple was back to resistant so
there's this stage here where the
microbiome has shifted both techniques
are able to organize the data well as
rest of the animal slaves you have
controlled by its at a large zoom out
and you can see that visit effect on
both ones the next part though is very
difficult we want to pick biomarkers
from this data on the left hand side you
can see certain follow chip results of
different taxa that on the top left for
instance was low during the first phase
then midwife for the susceptible stains
phase and then it ended up being high at
the resistant phase what other cases you
can find places where on the third panel
from the right low and then high and
then though again so there's a diversity
of patterns and very nice reducible
ships among all the samples so the
hybridization technique allows you see
this the sequencing technique also found
some interesting significant differences
this if against level isn't as high and
we think Mimi's because there's so many
zeros in this data matrix as you can see
here in the very first one there's a
slight increase a slightly higher amount
in a resistant phase and the drops down
to pretty much zero at the other phases
that's me interesting as a maybe a
repressive a bacteria that bruises a
seed seed if but you don't see very made
a big variety of types of changes and
and is this this problem having a sparse
matrix is there's the reason why you
don't see as much heterogeneity among
different patterns so then this post let
these cases into the top 12 biomarkers
from both pipeline from the samples from
both pipelines so the phyllo chip
produces greater number of civic and
biomarkers and it was able to uncover a
wider range of population detector ease
and if you compare them as far as like
and having bottom workers worked with in
lab on one side yet 153 that pass
certain tests the other one you had
eight so the key is if you can run both
of these analyses if you just it's going
to do 16s when both of these find
intersex and in the paper that we really
should a way you can find intersects
that might lead to prioritization the
biomarkers you want to follow up on so
that brings me to the end of the talk if
you are interested in accelerating a
biomarker discovery program and we can
work with you we have a contact here you
can hit us through a website but also if
you're an expert that's ready to already
impact health care the fresh approach
we're also hiring people so I'm putting
a plug out there also if he or somebody
who's interested in applying point of
our positions we have a careers page 2
takes your time I guess we have time for
some questions if if we have a couple
minutes so one of should i wait for you
okay um I have a question here of that
see how many times does the microbiome
how many times can it change well it
changes quite often we know there's
dietary effects with age effects of
course antibiotic usage makes a big
change as well so this is an interesting
reason why we think there's a
therapeutic avenue in microbiome
research although your genome doesn't
change your microbiome does can be
manipulated and I there's a ways you can
make more stable changes versus
transient changes so thanks raising that
question that's great let's see do we
any research for microbiome in autism
people penny research for micro violin
autism people well hi Todd um thanks
again for an excellent presentation and
answering or asking the first question
for me we just had a little bit of a
glitch but i just want to remind the
audience of how to submit questions you
can submit questions via the green eat
Q&A button that the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll continue
on with the question and answer session
the next question comes from oscar at
UAC gee who asked how many times does a
microbiome can change okay um yes that's
when I just answered and we think it can
change quite a bit depending on a diet
age antibiotic use for instance there's
ways that as many papers have shown that
your microbiome can change figure out
your life and even in weeks okay the
next question comes from one wing at the
molecular diagnostic lab consulting who
asked what is the spectra of chronic
disease that are regulated by microbe
microbes in some significant way
that's a great question the spectrum
diseases is broad as evidenced by the
literature that's really looked at many
different things and for instance you
know radiation disease has an effect and
there's people working to autism MS now
the areas that we have looked into most
closely there's a spectrum of changes
that are occurring that aren't the same
long every disease so for instance crc
was an area where we find pretty
significant changes and then IBD there's
different changes that occur depending
on your type of diabetes so for instance
Crohn's the changes that you see in a
stool sample aren't as dramatic as the
ones in UC and metabolic diseases to its
more subtle so I think the big question
asked the answer is still in the global
microbiome look is if you take all the
diseases and let's say your lipstick
with one stools type of specimens tool
and you have one extraction technique
and one data collection technique if you
take all that data set and then decide
if you can rank all diseases by what's
the effect size of microbiome I think
that's going to be an interesting
meta-analysis that's upcoming the trio
academic group must be having that
underway as well right now but it's a
it's a what you find is that when you
read one paper it seemed very important
because the focus is on that disease if
you put many different diseases on the
same scale you might be able to see
which diseases have the largest
microbiome effects that you can detect
also depends on what sample you're
looking at so a stool sample might not
be the best one for colitis maybe the
microbiome change that's occurring in
the mucosa which is where the actual
disease area is it's going to contain
much more information and so for
instance not taking the easiest
biospecimen but finding the spot
specimens most appropriate will affect
how you pick your bio markers
great and next we have a question from
James to ask does the innate immune
system link the nutrient dependent micro
RNA home to the akola ecological
adaptation and biodiversity via the
human gut microbiome metabolic networks
genetic networks and RNA mediate amino
acid substitutions yes so we think so I
mean the immunologist that are here at
second genome and I definitely have a
focus on the innate immune system and
there there's plenty of links now the
micro RNA oh my can't really comment on
but we expect that micro RNA is of
course can control gene expression
there's a big question out there whether
some of the microbes themselves have
adapted techniques to manipulate gene
expression at the micro RNA level so you
know hypothesis that might be underway
at University for instance might be that
if you took all the transcripts made by
the microbiome which of those match
micro RNA controlling structures in
other words can match a an area that
could silence gene expression and is
there a way to get that DNA I get those
RNA transcripts in enough to have
control and so there's that microbes
have adapted ways to control their
environment maybe using my corona also
of course the metabolic networks we
think are very interesting because the
metabolites that the microbes can
produce or consume and some of those are
like games themselves receptors that
trigger a name or sorry innate immune
systems so I hope that answers your
question
okay and next we have another question
from Oscar who asked you have any
research from microbiome in autism
autistic people I guess I should mark
that one as answered yeah I'm work that
was the answer is we talked about that a
couple times next we have a question
from one who asks about the accuracy on
identification of bacteria yes if it is
possible to assign um sorry I'm trying
to read it down here is it possible to
assign species level names with only 500
nucleotides with 16s rrna genes if not
genus level is it enough for pathogen
identification and are you improving
identification with longer reads and do
you think that the movement in this
field is going to pack bio or a nanopore
lots of questions great questions and
500 basis can be enough to make a
species call if the reference database
is unique in that region for that
species now if you're looking at ecoli
strains we're trying to Frenchy 8e coli
from salmonella you might have a hard
time doing that the 16s gene looks very
similar when those species but there's
some eubacterium for instance that have
distinct 16s gene even though they are
closely related general or the species
are on the same generous oh and there's
not a one answer fits all the question
always is given the reference database
and given the sequence length and region
that you selected to amplify and you can
pre look at the reference database and
see if there's a significant difference
between reference genes so of course
longer is always better
more variable regions you cover the more
likely you are going to be able to
differentiate organisms but i would say
that in most cases when you have a 16s
gene that you've seen as a civic and
change it might you should prepare that
it maps to multiple genomes in other
words multiple strains and sometimes
those strains are in different species
and the word species really is a
historical word where ordinance has been
named a certain way when you actually
treat them out you don't always see the
same monophyletic branch for what we
call a species before but suffice it to
say that once you have a 16s biomarker
there's probably multiple strains that
it could be coming from so it's always
good to have a follow-up technique
metagenomics I'm going to a qpcr for
other genes on that genome to
differentiate if you need to get a
strain level for us when we want to do
some protein mining well if the other
six units change that maps to let's say
five different genomes we can mine
proteins from all those genomes as long
as you have a medium or high if you put
a processing pipeline for your proteins
so if you don't have that then you might
want to have some upfront work to
distinguish which strain you have great
question now when it comes to lumen on
Pat bio i can give you my opinion on
this sorry Pat bio versus nanopore the
PacBio system from what I understand has
some higher error rates but if you can
circularize your DNA and pass over it
multiple times of sequencing that helps
correct it as so when alumina is able to
do let's say a lap three or four times
around 1500 base pair segment then that
should be really an excellent technique
to differentiate you know different
species the downside is it might be
expensive to do millions of reads at
that level and so let's kind of see now
her alumina has any machine out it's a
smaller footprint it's a bit less
exposed operate so that might be a
change I definitely kept up with what
their new price points going to be for
that product nanopore data have looked
at myself but what's exciting about that
is maybe this portability to be able to
take it into the clinic or on location
at a.m. and by methyl site so i think
that's promising to but the key thing is
multiple variable regions all nine would
be the best
and that having a technique that can do
look at all trillion molecules in a
sample that you prepare and those are
what we need to get to eventually I
think you alluded to this answer earlier
but um pool ass boy essa from her lab
development ass are there any uh sorry
just lost it are there any general
characteristics required for inter ideal
internal controls in molecular assays
great question and yeah this is a topic
that I put in the abstract but I didn't
have time to get to but this is a very
important dear to my heart issue the
general characteristics for internal
controls should be this they should be
able to be spiked into every single
sample and not interfere at the sample
itself they should be quantitative
meaning that there's a whole ladder of
these spike ins so that you can be sure
that across all your samples if you have
this molecule in there at one
ten-thousandth of the max that every
measurement you've made for all samples
also so shows it at one ten-thousandth
the max and if you have enough room for
these spikes into every year system is
and then you should be able to detect
changes in those spikes by put spiking
different amounts of the different
materials so this has been difficult in
NGS sequencing because by putting spike
ins into your NGS you actually using up
your reads that you want for your sample
so we found this it's more simple do
that with hybridization so for instance
in every single 16s follow chip there's
a panel of 20 spike in genes that aren't
16s they're just foreign alien genes
that goes into every sample and then you
can look at after you're done with all
your sample processing and data analysis
you can be sure that those proteins were
measured at their correct concentrations
and a very little variation across all
samples then you can you see that
to be able to say that I was able to do
quantitative analysis on this otherwise
you don't know when your actual analytes
are changing the concentration if that
was a depth question if that was a
biological change or just technical
error so being able to have a technical
spike in into all your samples whether
it be sequencing the tablet omics has an
easy way to do this then I think that's
really important so thanks bring light
up okay next we have another question
from one at life sequencing glass wine
Greenjeans database is better than our
DP database where green jeans is smaller
great question thank you for bringing
that up so really there's multiple 16s
databases that are out there and rdp the
ribosome database project from Michigan
is an excellent resource and so is Silva
which is another one that's maintained
in Germany and so there's no reason why
you couldn't try all of them and find
out what the pros and cons are the
reason that I like green jeans and the
roots of it is because the backbone
behind green jeans is an actual tree
that's created de novo often the 16s
diversity that's seen among organisms
I've been cultured in on cultured so in
the 2013 version at that point all the
data was taken as a snapshot in time a
tree was created and then a rational
system of placing names of different
nodes was applied so instead of using a
subjective measure to side window in the
tree should be the genus in which nodes
you get the word enterobacteriaceae in
which once you get a pseudo an ad ACA
and the historical nomenclature which
uses a guide but the tree itself was
used determine amount
clinic group so for instance it's hard
to differentiate ecoli and serratia in
this tree and so it's unclear whether
Ecola and serration service of the new
names like salmonella are really truly
monophyletic general or really they are
just different strains that are very
closely related and so the green jeans
tree helps reflect that now in an
upcoming version the tree won't be made
just on the 16s jeans but the tree is
made actually by calculating distances
across multiple genes in the genomes the
genomic sarah has really flourished with
luminol 454 sequencing so many more
genomes have been drafted and some of
these genomes even have a good 16s gene
sequence not all of them but many of
them have a good 16s gene and that we
can pull out along with the other genes
that code for other proteins and then
create one tree and I know that efforts
underway it UC Berkeley and you were to
clean Queensland Queensland in these
universities have different of different
let's say opinions about which genes to
use but the key thing is it's a
reproducible way to come up with a
taxonomy instead of historical
nomenclature winning out and I think rdp
it's still good focus on the birdies
manual for nomenclature which is fine
and I think it's a great historical
waiting to go forward boost Oracle way
to keep those names preserved over time
but I the molecular methods that drive
taxonomy are going to keep maturing and
green jeans focus has been to stay with
those likely methods
okay and next we have another question
from one leaf who asked you study
microbiomes and other organs besides
stool great question um yes absolutely
you know I think a lot of people when
they hear microbiome I think school and
when I hear microbiome I think of just
communities of bacteria to interact with
each other so that microbiome can exist
on your skin it can exist in your mouth
it can exist on a service that you've
touched or air that you inhale so yeah
we work on a lot different types so for
instance a oral biopsies of cancer
patients have been interesting we have
lung sputum that we've looked at from
cystic fibrosis patients of course you
talked about biopsies of the gut lining
that are also really interesting skin is
more difficult to work with but we also
do microbiome work on skin samples so
there's different partners and clients
that have come to us with different
hypotheses and they're going to
collected the right source not all those
hypotheses and require a stool sample so
absolutely i think the the literature's
full of examples of reliable ways to get
DNA or RNA out of samples besides just
school schools just very popular one to
work with good to know so we have time
for one last question who comes from
corrine class if you can comment on the
influence of dietary habits on the
universality of these biomarkers
it definitely reduces the universality
of the biomarkers because diet
interactions with the microbiome are
real so this is why we like these
studies where we have cohorts from
different parts of the world eating
different diets and sometimes different
age groups as well this is the only way
to get robust biomarkers you're trying
to find biomarkers that are present in
the disease state not a healthy state
irrespective of some of dietary changes
now sometimes it's hard to be convolute
so for instance certain IBD patients eat
certain foods more often than non IBD
patients and so there's that compounding
variable look at that can occur as well
so the the big answer there is multiple
cohorts and don't focus just on one
study if you're gonna start to be a
meta-analysis you want to pull lots of
studies together and see ones that have
have a variation that's not just
controlled by diet and but thousands of
samples are really useful for that thank
you okay well once again I'd like to
thank Todd 4 his fantastic presentation
it was really informative do you have
any comments final comments for us
before we go
sure yeah the final comments are just
basically a thank you to those of you
stuck with the presentation I definitely
feel like I how to gloss over a lot of
topics to get through a big overview in
one hour but you can email me at Todd
second genome if you have follow-up
questions happy to help out however I
can thank you well thank you once again
and I to remind the audience that
today's webcast would be on them
available for on-demand viewing through
to October of 2016 you receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when it's
available for on-demand and posted on
lap routes comm please feel free to
forward this announcement to your
colleagues to land this today's live
event thanks for logging in today and
participating and we hope to see you
again soon all right